and we run uh typically two programs
each semester
um that attract a bunch of long-term
visitors and include a boot camp and
several workshops
and this semester we're hosting two
programs entirely online
probability geometry and computation in
high dimensions and the theory of
reinforcement learning
and together these involve around 200
participants
so more than a usual semester welcome to
the final workshop of the reinforcement
learning program the mathematics of
online decision making
a big thank you to our events
coordinator
ashley hassan for all her work on the
logistics uh and to
omid far our videographer
and also a big thank you to our
organizers mehndi wang emma brunskill
and sean mine for doing a great job in
putting together an exciting program for
this week's workshop
i'm going to hand over to mengdie now to
say a few words about
this week's workshop um okay so hello
everyone and welcome to our last
workshop
uh so my name is mandy wong i'm a
professor at princeton university and i
work on rl
so i'll hand it over to emma and then to
sean
hi i'm emma brenskill i'm an assistant
professor of computer science at
stanford university where i focus on
reinforcement learning and
the technical questions that come up
when we think about applying that to
problems involving people like
healthcare and education
sean great thank you um so yes i'm sean
mine from the university of florida and
i work in reinforcement learning and
control systems now
application to energy systems and i was
asked just to say
a couple of words for the three of us so
first of all the best is left for last
this is a the entire um
program one of the things that's been
excited about it is that it's very
multi-disciplinary and i think this
workshop is probably the most
interdisciplinary of all the all the
workshops so far
some might ask what do we mean by batch
methods this is mainly
synonym for offline because there's been
a lot of emphasis
on sort of online analysis like in
bandits
and here we'll see a lot of that but but
it's a much much broader
discussion and a lot of simulation-based
techniques which are
inherently offline um the i mean
again just again the emphasis on
interdisciplinary nature of the
material we've have people from
statistics simulation control systems
curing theory
which means it's probably going to be
much more important to have
conversations
so please please come to the uh the
discussions the panels
and to gather town so we can have some
discussions and
get some new ideas
thanks sean and this is a reminder for
everybody the on the website
typical schedule yeah
all right well um and feel free to ask
questions in the q a
um and most speakers will always try to
give a little bit of space at the end of
the talk so um
to ask questions live as well as get
their tongue
um so uh my dear shout out we forget
anything or should we go ahead and
introduce sean i introduced shay let's
go ahead i think
you wanna i'm just trying wonderful well
we're really excited to have shaiminor
um kick us off this morning uh shai is a
professor of electrical engineering at
the technion um he graduated from there
with a phd in electrical engineering and
then was a fulbright scholar at mit
working with john
nicholas for a few years before holding
one of the canada
research chairs in machine learning over
at mcgill
and then he moved back to technion he's
been there for i believe about a decade
um in addition to doing a lot of really
foundational work and reinforcement
learning um
he also has been involved in a number of
different sort of industrial research
initiatives and is currently um the
distinguished scientists at nvidia
um he and his lab's work has won
numerous um awards um as well as he's
won numerous faculty awards
one of the most recent ones is an
outstanding best paper at
aaai 2019 um and uh and i always
uh um track their their labs work a lot
i think uh there's a lot of really
interesting um
work that they've been doing a number of
areas and i'm excited to see what he'll
tell us about today
thanks for joining us
so uh thank you emma thanks uh sean
mendy for uh
for putting this wonderful program
um so so today i'm going to talk about
um somewhat somewhat unusual
topic for my lab this is something that
we've started looking at in the written
the last
couple of years this talk is going to be
about online learning where you have
lots of
batch data but it's really about
an emergent marriage marriage between
two disciplines and that's uh
causal inference and reinforcement
learning so i i've been an arial person
and for this uh line of research uh i i
worked together with
uri shalit who's another professor at
the chechnyan who's a
causal inference uh person and uh
and this work will try to sort of figure
out what is uh
what is the joint between uh those two
disciplines and
we'll even show you a dictionary of how
to translate uh and uh causal inference
papers
paper to rl and vice versa so maybe you
can double dip and
uh and and get two papers for the price
of one
um so uh uh and the other collaborator
is my fantastic students uh guy 10 and
also
jonathan nefroni jonathan efron is a
former student he's now at msr
and guyton also did uh most of the heavy
lifting
uh in this work so without further ado
i'll start
and uh and i want to say that this is a
really a a
very much work in progress uh uh i'll
tell you about things that we're still
are still in the making like i think is
more appropriate for such a such
workshop
so uh the motivation is quite natural we
have
lots of data for different in different
domains
um so i've worked in the last few years
on autonomous driving
first or fourth and and uh and later and
now for nvidia a little bit
um and the problem is that uh you do
have a lot of offline data
uh uh but it's just offline data is is
partially observable you don't really
know think about thomas driving
you don't really know what exactly
happened uh to the car you don't know
what the driver
saw felt smell listened i mean you just
get the sensors and
and um and there are lots of uh things
that are happening
around you which and you don't have this
this awareness
and um what will will what is is
is knowing that when you have large
amounts of offline data
uh you can uh your estimates can be
confounded by a lot of
spiritual correlation and and in fact
what i will show today that uh
because of this issue of uh confounders
or partial observability things can go
uh
uh quite wrong and uh and i think that
it is for
for us as a community to figure out uh
how to remedy
uh the situation of having biased
estimates
uh because of uh of uh partial
observability
so so though when you you want to use
offline
offline data for rl then you basically
the basic problem is what we
know we call off policy evaluation so uh
basically
i have one policy uh uh and i want to um
from which all data was recorded i have
another policy that i believe
for some reason is is pretty good i want
to evaluate the new policy based on the
data that they have
before this is an age-old problem has
been studied uh at length uh
people have looked at it and at many uh
many situations um and um and we'll
talk a little bit more about situation
where you have you have a lot of offline
data but you also have
the ability to do some online uh stuff
so uh this talk will have really two
parts two technical parts
in the first part i'm going to talk
about bandits and in the second part i'm
going to
go uh go overboard and talk about pom
dps uh uh
so so let's start with the simplest case
the bandit case
and let's see what offline data can buy
you uh when
you're you're running uh uh bandits and
uh i
the stock was not planned for uh 25
minutes so what i'm going to do because
the slides are going to be in
in the in the in in the website i'm not
going to dive into some of the technical
details because
uh i'm not sure that they're relevant
for presenting all pictures but
nevertheless if someone is interested
uh the slides will be online uh shortly
after this talk so you can you can go
yeah
you can go and and dive into it and and
you'll you're always
welcome to shoot me an email and uh if
you have questions
i'll i'll hopefully uh respond shortly
okay so the first part is about linear
bandits
uh when your the data is confounded so
the setting is mixed you have a lot of
offline data but you also have access to
uh uh
to uh some online uh online uh
simulation abilities so it's a linear
contextual bandit so uh
just to to make sure that we're all on
the same page there are t
trials um that are sort of the online
trial that you have
there is a discrete action then there
are iid context
so the context think about like a vector
in uh in rd
the dimension is uh the context are
d-dimensional
and the reward is given by um an inner
product between uh
um between the the context and some
uh some weight vector and this weight
vector had you only known this weight
vector
there is no problem the problem is
easily solved so this is uh the
sort of the classical linear contextual
bandit
um and your objective is or the class
standard
objective is to minimize the regret uh
so this problem has been solved i think
with upper and matching lower bounds for
the online
online setting and and and now the
question is really what
is what can we do when we have offline
uh offline data
uh just to make sure that we are on the
same page the regret is uh
how much you get so this is uh the
uh the the uh the this
uh this is what the best pulse is going
to give you
and this is how much you actually got in
the time t and usually we look at
expected regret
so this those are linear bandits and
then we have i'm giving you a
ah sort of a treat i'm telling you you
don't have to solve the linear brand
problem uh basically i also i'm going to
also be giving you offline data
so the offline data was generated by
some unknown
fixed behavior policy pi b
but only l features of the context are
visible in the data so
there are d features in the online case
and there are only l
features in the offline recorded data
and for the sake of uh of the notation
we denote by uh
x observed and x hidden x o superscript
o and x superscript h
the observed noun unobserved feature of
the context uh
respectively so that's to to
um to see the picture so uh um
there is a lot of offline data in this
offline data uh we only get to see
uh l um sorry we're going to get uh
we're only going to see
um
the d minus l uh samples and then in the
online data we get to see all
uh the descent these dimensional samples
and now we want to make sense out of uh
out of everything so basically the
question is uh
if we can even use uh those uh the
offline data like
how how would you go about uh using that
so uh one one approach would we just
ignore so
basically let's suppose that we ignore
that the data is partially
uh observable so in that case we can
solve for example the least squares
uh problem um and and that um we can
let's suppose for now even little sooner
two you have
a lot of offline data so you have even
infinitely many
uh there is none infinitely many uh data
points so there is a
assuming under some some minor
assumption
on the on the behavioral data pi b then
you don't need to sample
there is no question here of uncertainty
uh so you can uh
the question is whether this uh the
solution of the least square problem
uh is meaningful for the original bandit
problem and remember that the issue
with uh with the vanity problem that
there are correlation between different
features so the different features are
are heavily correlated potentially okay
so so basically uh one thing that you
can you can easily show with that uh
if under some minor conditions uh the
solution that you solved uh that we
that we we can solve by by uh um by a
least square uh
problem uh and and that's uh essentially
reduces the dimensionality
of the space that you need to work in
from uh from d
to uh d minus uh minus l so you get uh l
linear
uh uh observation linear dependencies
on on the data that uh that you have
and um and basically what what what is
is possible to do because you can
achieve a regret
that instead of having a dependency like
d square root of kt which is what you
would expect you can have
d minus l square root of kt so
uh um and and then uh basically you need
to do so
to go through some uh some mathematical
digits which i don't want to go uh
uh to go into but the point of this uh
exercise which you can see in the slides
uh uh at a later point is that you can
reduce your regret from uh
from a a linear factor in uh in
d to d minus l and and presumably if
if d is and if l is very close to d so
if
if you you manage to get most of the
observation of dimensionality
observation
uh uh is uh is high then uh your problem
become much
much easier so i'm going to skip those
parts
and and basically um
the main result here that you can you
can run an
awful type algorithm off of the optimism
first of uh
of uncertainty uh that will get you and
and the details are are i think less
important
a regret which that depends on d minus l
rather than uh
then d so so the conclusion of the story
here is that you can use offline data
it reduces your uh your actual
online complexity and that confounders
matter
so it is important uh to actually be
able
to have offline data and even if this
offline data is not exactly
the same as the online data it still
gives you value so
conclusion is never throw a data away
okay so so this was a warm up to just to
show that there is value
in offline data and let now let's talk
about
uh offline of off policy evaluation in
rl in general
and uh and what i'm going to do i'm
going to start with uh
initially even just explaining the
problem so suppose we have data that is
generated by
pi b that's our behavior policy so we
have different trajectories
and those trajectories just are state
action reward state action rewards and
so forth
so maybe you have many of those uh so
you can if you want you can build uh you
can be the model
so so the problem of uh of uh evaluating
a new policy in mdp is this is a well
studied problem you can do
important sampling you can try to reduce
the virus of important sampling there
are different things you can do
those are uh i think pretty well
established you can compute the
the variance of the estimation uh even
you can you can have error bounds and
and so forth
um so so uh um so in a mark of the in an
mdp problem
uh uh setting uh this is uh i'm not sure
if i would say the solved problem but
it's a
it's a very well understood problem
there are direct methods uh there are
important sampling methods there are
doubly robust estimates
um all are important and and
and valued contributions but but the
question that i'm asking is
we let's suppose that we've solved mdps
we can we can argue about that later but
how do i even define off policy uh
estimation under partial observability
so when i don't have full observability
when i don't have an mdp
a situation uh but rather a pom dp
situation whether they're observing
there is some partial observability then
it's not even clear
how do i do that how do i even evaluate
uh how do i even define the off policy
estimation problem
so so let's start with um an example so
this example is an example
of uh of uh pro probabilistic
maintenance it is it's a classical
example in operations research um so uh
suppose you have uh we have a machine
that is other that we need to
maintain on a monthly basis um every
month an expert comes
checks the machine machine listens to it
knocks on it and then tells us
if we should fix it or not fix it um and
the expert knows by the expert actually
knows whether
it's the machine is working properly and
then they can decide if they want to fix
the machine or not so let's see an
example so
so as it's a it's a mock-up example so
we have a
machine which is either working or uh or
broken and their actions
are fixed or not fixed so maybe the
dynamics looks something like that if
it's working and we fix it then it's
fixed
if it's uh if it's a broken
and we decide uh if sorry if it's um
if it's working and then uh we decide to
um
if it's broken inside to fix it then
it's fixed
and this is sort of the rest of the
thing let's assume that there was a
probability of 0.9
uh uh that it's uh that it it will
if we don't fix it and it's working that
it's uh
will stay uh uh will stay working and
0.1 it will
uh it will broke it will it will uh
break down
so this is a pretty simple uh problem
and just for a second of discussion
let's make the rewards
minus one if uh if we if we uh
uh we fix and uh if it's broken then we
get a minus uh
uh minus ten so it always always costs
us to uh
cost us to um uh when the machine is in
a broken
uh situation and let's suppose that the
historical policy is uh to
is to fix when it's working that
probability is 0.9
and and to fix when it's broken i was
probably
um when it's working to fix it at 0.1
and when it's broken to fix it with 0.9
this is just an
illustration okay but we only see noise
due observations like we don't have
access to the export itself we see
we see for example say the temperature
of the machine so
if the machine is working maybe we see
that it's hot
uh with a probability of 0.1 and that
it's normal with
0.9 and the other way around when it's
broken
so so again for the sake of illustration
we don't have
a perfect observability of the true true
state
of of the machine so uh we can do
important sampling
at the function of the state uh then
state unknown to us
or we can do important sampling uh when
when the pomdp environment which is
really what we have
but now it's of a function of the
observation hot
or or cold or not hot uh so so now uh
we can use look at those two um uh two
uh estimators
uh for example the function of the
horizon h okay and this is uh what we do
here is uh
is precise so we don't the estimation
has nothing to do with this
and we would look at the horizon and
look at that at the estimation and this
is sort of the true
important sampling estimation had we
seen the state
and um i don't even remember what pi
uh e here uh pi pi pi b is uh
the expert pulse in pi is is something
else that
not really important and pi and and pi
which would have called it naive is a
function of the
observation so we see that there is a
divergence here so
basically our our our important sampling
as estimation
uh of the of the uh of the value of the
policy
the pause estimation becomes worse and
worse than the horizon becomes uh
longer which means that basically our
belief becomes random
once our belief becomes random then we
don't know what we're doing we're just
making a blunder and often estimate
so this example which is an exact
computation just goes to show you that
if you're
going to replace the point sampling of
the function of state with important
sampling of the function of observation
even in this very simple two-state true
observation to action problem then
uh then things are not going to work uh
work well
okay so so the first question that we
asked is how we even define
uh um ope uh
policy evaluation of policy evaluation
under partial
observability so so let's talk about
pomdps
uh and and what i'm going to do now that
i'm going to introduce
the notation used by our friends uh who
are
uh who are in into causal inference so
uh uh in in in a point dp situation
there is a state
s0 this is uh for let's suppose for now
this is not random
and somebody observes this state as zero
and
this person who is using the behavior
policy the expert in the in the
maintenance example
is going to choose the action a0
now a0 and s0 both affect r0
this is a reward at time 0 and then
s0 and a0 both affect s1 so this is
really an
mdp representation of uh
of a causal or this is called a causal
inference diagram
and and this just tells you what
variables
affect which variable so in this case s1
is affected by
a0 and s0 so the state at time 1 is
affected by the action
and by this by by the action times 0
and the status times you but note that
this for example is not affected by the
reward
at time zero that's sort of the standard
mdp notation and now we can continue to
the next step
and the next step in the next step and
the assumption here is that uh the
behavioral policy is cognizant of the
state itself
so it actually gets to see the state uh
itself and this can continue okay
now what happens for the uh for the um
in the partial observability case so now
there is a state s0 it affects an
observation at time zero uh we or
the agent or whoever we're trying to
evaluate gets to see the observation but
they know
does not get to see the states so now
they can use this observation
to form an action a0 as a result
the reward is is is uh r0 is is now
depends on
s0 and a0 note that the reward does not
depend on
on on o0 because conditionally
conditional the action the reward is
independent this is sort of the stunt
assumption
in mvps and we can we can continue for
moving to the next state
and and now for the for the next action
so tonight
it's sort of important to understand
that when uh when the
i evaluate the policy i can take a look
at um
at uh the observation at time zero the
observation at time one and use both of
them to form
the action at time one so the action
time one does not have to depend only
on o and it can depend in principle on
the on the entire history
and now we can continue with uh with
this uh uh uh with this diagram
to get s1 to get us s2 and uh
and and and similarly to before uh the
action at time too
can depend on the whole history of the
observations but it cannot depend for
example on the actual states
so this diagram which is the conditional
independence of
of the decisions tells us the
probabilistic story and that's what
causal inference people
uh seem to care about the most and this
is something that uh
if if there is one thing you want to
take from this talk that uh
those diagrams tell a whole different
story of what depends on
on what okay um so uh
just uh to make sure that we're on the
same page here
um so the the um the behavioral policy
can depend on the state
therefore the state uh is going to
affect the action so you see the
the lines between s0 and a0 between s1
and a1
and so forth the uh the the policy that
we want to evaluate pi e uh depends only
on the observations
and the example here i omitted the lines
between um
uh between um uh uh o
zero and and uh and a1 and and uh a2 but
that's uh
just for uh for clarity so now we have a
picture of
of pomdps and uh and mdps and
what is uh the behavioral policy uh that
depends on the states rather than the
observation
and the uh and pi which
which depends on the observations and
not just the states
okay so this is what we see we see
the observation begets actions
observation begets action observation
via
action but what created the data is a
somewhat different process
the s0 created a0
and then s0 and a0 created a1 and so
forth and the observation itself
is in fact um once the the state is
and once the action is chosen the
observation is not
does not change anything at this point
and and that's sort of the palmdp
uh model okay so so the goal of
of policy evaluation and point of ps is
to evaluate the value
of uh of pi e using the measure uh um
over the observable trajectories being
the trajectory that uh uh
only have state observation action
reward observation action reward uh
because we may not be privy to the to
the state uh itself
so this is the really the goal of of pom
dp
evaluation and at this point uh um
we're not sure what to do so uh we asked
our friends who are doing causal
inference
and to me that's uh perhaps other slides
you need to remember and that's uh
causal inference can offer quite uh
quite a a quite a bit of um
of insight to rl especially to off
policy
evaluations uh and to uh problems of
partial observability
so um um so when when you do off policy
evaluation
uh um you do not have access
to the same data that the agent has and
a good example is a physician's treating
treatment in icus um and and basically
the issue that there is a state this
state is
is may not be uh observed by even the
physician but
even if he does all that we get usually
to see are the observations so
measurements uh um and actions um
that were made by the physician but
we're not exactly sure
why the physician made whatever
observation
and those uh underlying reasoning
reasons for making this
those uh those decisions are what we
call confounders so this is something
that we don't know
why we don't have we may have we may
never know why but we still want to be
able to do a false evaluation
and that seems a little bit like magic
because there is no way for us to even
know
where this uh what are the confounders
but still we want to be able to do
something
uh which is uh interesting and there are
sort of two fundamental
fundamental questions here is first what
you cannot do so
give a think about those impossibility
results or lower bounds
or basically tell you like what you
cannot do with uh this offline
data and positive results under which
cases
actually you can perhaps surprisingly do
something with the offline
uh data so uh we created a dictionary to
be able to work on those problems
and this is really a dictionary for you
uh for you to use and one thing one you
can think about that you have uh
what what we call states observed or not
are uh they call confounders uh what we
call actions they call treatments what
we call reward vehicle
outcomes what we call behavioral policy
they call
the the treatment process what we call
observations they call proxy variables
so it's a bit uh weird
uh to use their language but
nevertheless they were first so i think
we should give them
uh some credit and then in terms of
things that you can do there are
typical activities uh that uh you can
think about it and they call them they
use a specific
language so they talk about association
as what we would call observing
uh intervention as as as doing
actions in our language and uh
counterfactual is uh
i think imagining or retrospecting
something we don't
typically do and then and that's
something that is also uh um
also uh important so those are the three
layers of causal hierarchy and and we as
real people i think should be cognizant
of what they're doing
and understand the implications for uh
for us
so so uh in in a recent paper we showed
that uh
um under some invertibility assumptions
which i'll
i'll show on the next slide but i'm not
going to uh to discuss just to make sure
that whoever is interested uh can later
check but basically if the are in if the
dynamics are
invertible and there are enough
observations you can essentially
propagate back
and figure out what exactly uh happens
so you can you can
derive a function which may be
complicated but still a function
of the observable data that would give
you uh
uh the off policy evaluation so this is
a
theorem i i i'm just putting it for for
me a short
second uh because this is something that
you can read uh uh later it's it's just
uh something technical
but uh but there is something that is um
uh more interesting here i think and
that's the causal structure of the
dp is something that is somewhat
unnatural and it's a in some sense it's
a little bit too uh
too descriptive so they're they're
really we have
technically we need to invert uh large
mattresses but also where
the structure itself is not um is not
too comfortable to work with
so so we don't know how to solve it for
general palm dps we don't know how to do
off policy evaluation
for general public peace we suspect it
is uh impossible
uh but one thing that we can do is to
define a specific uh
uh type of bomb dp's so what we call the
coupled palm dps
and this is really the slide i want to
go to get into
so so here we have a palm dp on the left
and on the right we have a decoupled
palmdp
and you present it from a causal inte uh
causal uh um
uh from a causal uh inference uh
perspective so
so we have observations on the palm dp
the observations are
we call them zed and u is uh the state
and this is a
historical policy and this is just a
recap
of uh what we showed before for a palmdp
so uh there is a state uh u uh it
creates observations
uh for the case of um of uh of
um uh of the um uh
um of the behavioral policy depends on
the actual state
the uh the the evaluate policy depends
on on what you get to observe
and this is uh the pump dp structure
this is very general
so we took what we're doing on on the
right we're trying to
to simplify it so we create uh the state
which now is is uh
both we decouple it to two parts one
particle
is that and the other is you that is
is really what uh uh what um
is a decoupling of the state so that um
so that there is some part of it which
is sort of um
observed and some part which is not and
then we also have uh
the observations which are uh fully
observed
so so let me explain how how this works
the observations uh once an observation
happens and
nothing depends on it the behavioral
policy can depend on the two parts of
the states but cannot depend on
observations
and uh the policy that we're trying to
evaluate
can depend on on the z observations
those are sort of the actual
observations we see and
also on the on on the observations but
it cannot depend on the hidden part of
the state
so by doing this decoupling to
observations
hidden state and observed state we get
to the point where
this is a different type of 1dp it's
certainly not the most general one
but this decoupling allows us
essentially to do this uh
to do the off policy evaluation for
this particular type of of pomdps
so uh i'm uh i'm out of time
as expected um but uh the conclusion
that uh
uh that i want to to to to draw that
there is a bias that is inherent when
you're doing uh using off policy data
uh in the bennett case this was sort of
simple it was clear that whatever you
don't see you don't know
what to do about but you you can still
leverage uh
what you see there um about in the in
the
mdp or pompdp case it became quite
interesting
and uh what we've done is we chose easy
way out so we use uh uh causal inference
uh terms
uh to get a clean solution by this
partitioning to observe state and
non-observed
state um but there is a still a very
long way to go of
measuring how how much something is
observed and how
and what is a causal relationship
between
different objects and also to
statistically uh eval validate
uh those things so i think that uh um
at least from my conclusion from this
line of research is that
causality and ariel go better together
so
uh thank you i know it took a little bit
more too long but
still i think i hope it was at least a
little bit interesting
okay so we're going to defer all the
questions to the break
and so we're going to move on to our
second talk
um so yandong kian
is a lead research scientist at facebook
ai research
and yandong is a hardcore theoretician
and the engineer
so soyendo works on like deep learning
theory reinforcement learning theory
and a bunch of direct machine learning
topics and he's also a hardcore engineer
and he almost single-handedly developed